because the second you're like well I
can I can do this you know that's pretty
boring work you know I almost didn't do
this uh show devil in Ohio that uh came
out on Netflix last month because
it was a contractor and a family man and
I and they were like hey they really
want you to audition for this and I said
well if they need to see what I'm liking
that there's 103 episodes of a show
called Parenthood and they can look at
that I've done that yeah and come on
this is easy yeah yeah but you know
again did they do that no they were like
well they they just like to see you uh
sometimes it's more about let's see if
we like this guy right if we want to
work with it right let's see what he
gives us let's see his interaction with
us he's going to be easy it's gonna be
one of those pains in the asses that's
always calling us or lines and late to
work yeah always friendly which I guess
I like Sam so that this is
funny so this is funny I I actually had
this this conversation with my team I
read this book
um uh called predictably irrational and
it was all about how the Myriad of ways
we make decisions and how
um we think there's sound you know paths
but they're really arbitrary and silly
means by which we we make our decisions
and I said so Guys these these people
want me to audition for a show I don't
know these people from Adam but I read
this book and one of the things that
they said is a good predictor of whether
you can you know whether people feel
invested in you is whether they feel
like a connection I have no connection
with these people so what I need to do
is if we can get the Creator on the
phone I can talk to her for 10 minutes
and then we have a relationship and
that's what we did I met Darian we
talked on the phone and after 10 minutes
we hit it off she had just had a baby
boy I had three boys we could talk about
that and uh I grew up in Ohio so I could
talk at nauseum about growing up in Ohio
and how specific it is and um
and so when I auditioned I said okay now
I'm comfortable to put myself on tape
for this and work and so when we did the
audition it was just a work session
because she was already invested and so
at any given moment I'm always like okay
can we get the Creator on the phone
because that's gonna go get me so much
further than whatever audition we send
out into the ether because I know
there's they're saying 400
tape on this and we're all pretty much
the same right and I also think that
I've said this before but there's
something but when you get an offer for
something you're like okay they want me
I wonder what kind part of me they want
what is what is it they want yeah and
then you're just unsure
but if you audition and they like it and
they cast you like I know what they want
exactly I gave them what they wanted
yeah there's some comfort actually in a
weird way about auditioning that I I
don't like auditioning I'm not I don't I
just have to put a lot of time into it
it's a lot of work it's a lot of like I
have to put to be my best I need a week
yeah I can't uh I've never even when I
wasn't
known at all
when I wasn't on the Spectrum I I would
my well that sounds
but my agents would say you know I go
listen
I'm not I I can't do more than one
audition in a week maybe two if it's a
Monday and a Friday right but I just
can't I can't I can't multitask I can't
I have to stay in this character read
for it and then move on but yeah that's
just something I just if I'm gonna be at
my best absolutely do you feel like that
totally yeah and there are things I put
on tape and I'm like uh yeah I mean it's
good enough but I don't you know
foreign